[Music]
honestly it's hard to just go back into
Ingo like here's what I like here here's
what I like here because a lot of time
when I said here does I like here it's
just a shot in the finale when the Indo
Raptors are going after Bryce aw hi
refers pride and clone girl and then
there's this one shower Chris Pratt's
trying to go for a gun and then Bryce
Howard pulls him back and the camera
like pans up you see they like the -
there's like on top like that's cool but
I'm not gonna do a whole spoiler talks
describing shot see you guys and this
one image was laying down with floors
like highlight parts I'm really talking
about it get part where the t-rex comes
out roars and a lion is cool cool image
Rhett two different kings of the animal
you ended
[Music]
hey reject nation I'm Greg elbow I'm
John and I'm the real mr. Robinson real
mr. Robertson Robinson Robinson
Robertson he had we had a whole
operation about this Alex
Robinson yes the real mr. Robertson is
here we are gonna do a review a spoiler
talk of Jurassic world falling Kingdom
because of the fact that the trailers
reveal about ninety eight point nine
percent of the movie might as well just
do a spoiler review of the film for you
guys before going into this review I
wanted to say a quick thank you it's a
medium nation for their MX 4d experience
because they hook us up with screening
tickets at the man Chinese theater for
the MX 4d I gotta tell you opinion aside
on the movie the experience of the MX
forty especially with the opening
sequence of this film made it that much
better like a million times better
oh yeah the motion effects the rain
effects the fog effects like it's really
immersive it was very immersive and it
does add is kind of extra rollercoaster
feel to a movie that's already
attempting to do that for you thank you
guys so much for hooking us up if you
guys want to experience a cool 40 X
experience MX 4d you could catch at the
man Chinese Theatre it's totally worth
it in the first like 10 minutes of this
movie you get here everyone letting out
a motion over the experience of it it
was really well worth it to do that
myself
cuz the whole time I'm just sitting here
like I was a part of it sorry mr.
Robertson but anyway let's hop into our
review of Jurassic world falling Kingdom
we're gonna treat this spoiler review in
a way where you have already seated I
know sometimes when people do spoil the
reviews they try talking in a way as if
they're gonna you know ruin a movie for
you and like setting up Plaza we're not
gonna talk that way for you guys we're
gonna talk as if you have already seen
just a real conversation with you guys
Alex you can catch his non-spoiler
review over his actual channel I guess
we'll just give our super quick thoughts
before hopping into a spoiler discussion
I this movie better than an awesome 40 X
experience
looking at going what's better Jurassic
Park 3 or Jurassic or falling Kingdom I
felt Jurassic Park 3 is more boring but
I feel like this one is a lot more
irritating I was surprised by how
irritated I was most of the time I was
watching it I wouldn't say I was bored a
lot of people say they gets bored you
you said you got bored a lot and it took
it took a long time to grab me with much
of anything I was more entertained by
how baffled I was especially in the last
half of this movie there's already stuff
in the first half that is better than
the last half but the last half
especially had me going what why I don't
get it
why is this in the movie yeah I was
visibly like face palming myself just
looking down at the screen with my hands
covered like I didn't want to be a
theater with a bunch of people around me
who are loving it
some of them I actually work with there
there were times where I think our whole
group would just throw our hands up in
the air like what's going why are they
Hamid I think what makes this film so
much different than Jurassic world
because I know you're not a fan of
Jurassic world I don't hate it
but it's it's a mixed bag it's a mixed
bag I know you pretty much feel that way
I felt like hey I know Jurassic world
ain't no Jurassic Park it's cheesy
it's corny it's ridiculous and there's
some stupid characters in it but I still
feel like Colin Trevorrow direction he
knew what he was making that movie has
fun with its dinosaur stuff that's the
that's the thing is it knows what it is
it knows its tone it's consistent with
its tone I am a million times more
forgiving with everything in that movie
as just a pure piece of entertainment
cheese throw ride with some you know
two-dimensional characters of terrible
villain of Vincent D'Onofrio it all just
makes me laugh but I feel like the movie
knew what it was at what it was doing
this movie has this dour town it is
arguably the most depressing Jurassic
Park movie ever
and so the BVS of Jurassic it is because
it also bothers to like bring up
a lot of great concepts about ethics and
what not inside chaos and it doesn't do
anything with any of them and it tries
to be different by taking it off the
aisle so this is a lot of stuff that on
paper an idea format that I'm like I
appreciate that
I'm glad you you decided it but they
never fully meet it for me the problem
with a movie like this is like we're II
watched the first Jurassic Park and
that's already an iffy idea just
bringing dinosaurs back the whole point
of that movie is like your scientists
were so preoccupied with whether or not
they could they just have to think of
this I should you have done this even if
you could and looking at it now I know
it only works then because it just gets
more stupid as we go it's like no we
shouldn't be doing any it has a lot of
these complaints specially about
villains and choices and rules of human
you know anatomy in certain situations
like Chris Pratt outrunning smoke it
just goes so far beyond the suspension
of disbelief by this point beyond that
it's be it's because of its tone that
its striking of why it's harder to
forgive it when the movie itself is
clear like you have a comic relief
character sure but beyond that it's
trying to convey a serious movie it's
trying to have a serious tone and
against all these dour heaviness the
dark film in a weird cheesy way I guess
to get some positives out of the way
like the general positives that I think
everyone's gonna [ __ ] tell you the
opening the opening is great it's cool
opening sequence the trailers literally
show you everything the t-rex is going
after that guy who's swinging off the
rope ladder on the helicopter and then
it's a cool moment and and the way it's
done is like a spooky monster film the
way they deal with lightning the t-rex
appearing in the background and it is
tense
it is suspenseful even if people forgot
that if you stand still she won't see
you absolutely
always gonna get that the most asaurus
appears and it would have been cooler if
the trailers didn't show you that but
the trailers show you that and then it
comes and kills and that's a really cool
sequence and the way it's executed how's
you going oh this might be just an
actual cool like spooky fun thrill ride
with dinosaurs and then the movie kind
of just begins one thing I like about
this movie of that I thought they
actually improved upon and this is a
very slight thing is Bryce Dallas Howard
specifically her and even the chemistry
between Bryce Dallas Howard and Chris
Pratt to me they're like the new Fifty
Shades of Grey oh well here like man
they have no chemistry in the first one
and then you watch the sequel you're
like their chemistry is better Bryce
Dallas Howard is a character who I don't
hate this time around and I actually get
where she's coming from in this film
there's like that kind of what's the
word for it where you got like the guilt
conscience thing you just kind of repair
that by trying to help try to make
amends yeah you guys are the first movie
the dinosaurs from the island there's
apparently a volcano there that no to be
fair watching a second time because I've
seen it twice they said it was dormant
so that woke up
yeah like conveniently three years after
Jurassic world closed I'll give them
that reluctantly so the movie is dealing
with this theme of should these clone
animals should we let them live deserves
do we have to intervene and actually
help them out with surviving or should
we just let them go back into extinction
Bryce Dallas Howard recruits her
ex-boyfriend because I love when sequels
do that they're broken up at the very
beginning of their romances
life-threatening dinosaurs yes yeah
what's funny about this movie they
realized it has the same exact arc with
their relationship as the first one kiss
yeah even even the random kiss moment
you're like it's kind of more effective
here that's what gets these two people
off this exact kind of situation yeah
when they get back to normal life they
just split up again for me Jurassic
world
I like the dinosaur stuff and the
adventure I didn't like the characters
and I will say that in this movie I
liked Chris Pratt and Bryce Dallas
Howard a lot more and I did like the
addition of both the tech guy and the
vet you see I really felt like the tech
guy and the vet could have been combined
the tech guy kind of unnecessary for me
because of the fact that I felt 90% of
his jokes just did it land and it felt
like it kind of felt like worst comic
relief but I didn't think that was the
actors fault I guess I enjoyed watching
his performance he was one of the people
I was happy to see on screen even though
I do agree the comedy didn't click but I
thought the vet girl worked really well
though for the movie she was broke she's
far the best addition in terms of her
characters like she's not in the movie a
hell of a lot but she's one of the more
real characters she felt very real like
whenever she's standing up for the
dinosaur whatever situation she's in ORS
being a tough cookie I really bought her
and Bryce Taos hearted Chris Pratt and
they have the same [ __ ] setup if they
do in the first look of she needs to go
find something with this dinosaur
we need Chris Pratt's help you remember
they reunite like this is the exact he's
working on something he's in a bungalow
in a remote location exchange so when
they go to sit down and have beers I
actually bought their chemistry I
actually believe you guys have a history
and it took me for a loop do you like
what's going on with you actually
Brandon so even when they have their
kiss moment I bought it a little more
it's still felt a little bit like
Jurassic world where Jesus but but I
bought it yeah in Jurassic world it felt
like Chris Pratt going give me some
sugar baby yeah yeah yeah yeah they go
to the island there and and honestly
when they're at the island that's
probably the best part of the movie to
me the best part of Jurassic world and
this one is my favorite characters blue
maybe feel that blue to be honest I
don't see her as a character she's just
a velociraptor I think the character
comes in the dynamic between Chris Pratt
and blue that's when I'm gravitated
towards blue is when they're like he did
the whole and cooked click and yeah
dynamics different because in the first
Jurassic world she's very feisty she
doesn't listen a whole lot of Tours in
this movie they established that she's
the
kindest one she's the most obedient one
that's not at all what I remember from
the fourth movie guys yeah I don't
really care with J Bayona like the
director of this film
yes back when I was like you did the
impossible right the impossible possible
monster calls
yeah and they did the orphanage the
orphanage yes so he has a horror movie
background dealing with disasters and
monsters and that all really reflects in
the entire island sequence of the
volcano erupting and there's a lot of
fun moments to be had there and do these
trailers for the hell out of ya right
bro Chris Pratt shows up with blue and I
do like the chemistry between blue and
Chris Pratt especially was like looking
at the laptop and you said it best in
the movie was over the one thing this
movie really succeeds on is the moments
where they want you to go oh when you're
really earnest flavor for Jurassic Park
yeah when you're feeling bad for the
dinosaurs or when you want to think
these things are acute that's all really
effective and then sometimes it's kind
of manipulative to me when they first
show up to the island and then they got
the long neck rocky is right Thank You
Sarang bronchitis I'm Titus dinosaur
it's going back to you know like when
Sam Neill and Jeff Goldblum and Loranger
and saw that same dinosaur in part one
and it's such a remember Jurassic Park
one yeah and there's a lot of that in
this movie remember when Jurassic Park
was a good movie you know when this
series had integrity yeah and in that
moment it's doing this thing of wonder
and I feel like this movie so mismatched
in tones you got two different movies
here and I know we're kind of all over
the place here because it's movies all
over you got one movie that's talking
about animal clones and animal rights
and should we let these animals go
extinct should we take care of that
where did dinosaurs live amongst us this
other movie is dinosaurs are freaking
terrified they're riggan monsters and
we're spooky evil you know we need to
option them off to the 1% that are
trying to blend but not really doing it
but you got your wonder dinosaur here
and then after the island is covered in
lava and all the dinosaurs are dying
they have this shot that is so sad and
it's effective when the long necked
dinosaurs somehow makes it to the pier
yeah legs and then it's just getting
covered by the smoke and they're
watching it and I was going oh that's so
sad and the other side of my mind was
like [ __ ] you movie this I don't really
watch the wonder die before you're like
nasty monster movie afterwards but at
the same time it's kind of one of these
things were it's like maybe this is for
the good that this dinosaur dies in
Malcolm's in this movie for seven
minutes or maybe less is he shot for
seven minutes seven minutes he was in it
for less the he pretty much says this
volcano erupting is nature correcting
its course so we should just let them
die which could have been an interesting
debate had the movie bothered there was
one moment that despite the movie's
uneven tone that actually kind of made
me legitimate laugh Chris Pratt gets
started by the the drugs that like kind
of put you out yeah what he's trying to
say blue he's unable to move and then
there was a bunch of lava coming in
devouring everything scaring off a sinto
Serra tops I know these things
exactly and he's just doing the wolf of
wallstreet where he's trying to roll
away yeah I was genuinely funny yeah
keeps this movie engaging and
entertaining is that throughout the film
from beginning and there will always be
a moment or a little sequence or a shot
even that is really cool this movie is
filled with beautiful images yeah yeah
it's one of the better-looking ones I
think and that's the only reason why I
would kind of prefer it over Jurassic
Park 3 is because I still think it has a
style in its imagery I could give you
that yeah I think this was the wrong
script for Jay Bayona and what he's good
at but I think he does bring in
assuredness behind the camera at very
leaves yeah cuz when the islands
exploding you know there was some stupid
stuff that happens in it that I thought
was kind of like silly in the trailer
but even dumber in the movie when the
ball whatever that spear thing is and
they're rolling down before they
actually even get into the ball that's
when I thought a dumb moment occurred
where scary dinosaur occurs and then
they just start fighting with each other
for no reason what everyone's running
no reason you shows up as quietly as
possible nobody even sees it coming a
mile away in an open field and then
takes off yeah screw this as the
volcanoes erupting behind it after that
it just runs away cuz it's another
remember Jurassic Park one that was a
good movie wasn't it I hate anything
that's like remember dress it part one
like when the t-rex they bring back to
the mansion and then there's a goat yeah
and I'm like did they think this is what
the t-rex ate or is it
remember far 1d8 the goat or when or
when the t-rex ate the one bad guy she
poses in the exact same pose as in
Jurassic Park when the banner falls and
then she just runs away again yeah this
movies like this really serve as a
reminder for the toxic side of omage and
nostalgia to me because if there's
nothing beyond that at the core it
really does start to leave a sour taste
beyond that one moment it's a pretty
intense sequence and it's heartbreaking
when you're seeing all these dinosaurs
dying and falling off the cliff it
reminded me a lot of what I saw in the
impossible they're actually underwater
the spheres filling up with water and
Chris Pratt's trying to break them up
you think shooting a cone is gonna do
the trick this movie the definitions are
just stupid decisions throughout the
second he's shot I was like well it's
not gonna break the glass it's just
gonna fill with water faster yeah I
guess in a desperate situation you're
gonna try something desperate beyond
that one little moment though I thought
it was really cool how he kept it pretty
much in one shot Chris Pratt's trying to
break in he swims up to the top to get
some air it goes back down but they all
keep it in the one spear as it's filling
up with water like that's a cool
sequence that's a really cool moment and
then the movie like continues somehow
there's like these expendable private
military people who manage to go to this
island that is clearly being covered
by the world they managed to steal
dinosaurs and take them all the way back
to whatever state were in without anyone
detecting this not one government
official not one radar thing not one
satellite thing when the first 10
minutes of this movie or after the
prologue with the cool opening sets up
that the worldwide attention right now
was all on this island and there's
clearly coverage happening and the
coverage of the film is also saying
there's a volcano about to erupt there's
clearly cameras on this island right now
yeah even like shitty Isla Sorna in
Jurassic Park 3 had the Costa Rican
government be on alert if anything was
approaching it yeah and then here
somehow they just managed to Jack all
these dinosaurs you get these villains
in this movie that are basically the
stock Jurassic Park villains by now and
that's a major issue tonight I feel like
they need to get some fresh ideas I
don't know calling them stock Jurassic
Park villains is an insult to stock
Jurassic Park villains I feel you might
be right cuz like rapes ball shows up at
the beginning as this you know
benevolent you know financier this guy
who's taking over the mantle for the
Hammond you know institution and whatnot
yeah and you know right away this dude's
gonna be evil and then they meet this
soldier guy on the island who seems
pretty friendly but you know he's gonna
turn out to be evil and not only are
they evil to a stupid degree but they're
also just like despicable to the point
that they don't even feel like
characters at all I've got this hunter
guy like pullin teeth out okay clearly
he's got no regard for these and ya know
the movies gonna kill him horribly later
yeah they turn into cartoons like the
only way villains like this in a
live-action movie could have worked as
if they were with the Muppets I finally
started to latch on to this movie the
movie finally gave me something to hold
on to towards the end when I realize oh
I hate most all the humans in this movie
all of them are dumb and despicable abs
one-dimensional it really is like
one-dimensional know you want to see the
dinosaurs kill them and I think the
script even knows the humans are not
good it sounds like a bad slasher movie
we're like these characters are annoying
I want the killer to kill them this
movie is telling us the humans are bad
people we want the dinosaurs especially
scissors
so much sympathy for the dinosaurs and
then the humans you have zero sympathy
for when you're watching the movie
they're going to james cromwell's home
who literally does this entire role
while sitting or in his bed yeah okay so
there's a whole other plotline it's
totally unnecessary okay James Cromwell
who is I don't know someone who knew
John Hammond or whatever like his
partner or something yeah yeah they
didn't really get along and then he has
a granddaughter because Jurassic Park
needs a kid there's the successor to all
this who is the evil guy running
everything I have to ask you and my
girlfriend like for a second like wait a
minute
what are they doing because I thought
it's what they were doing I just had to
confirm what they were doing because I
just thought it was so dumb so they're
bringing back the dinosaurs they got
like what 11 to 15 dinosaurs or whatever
11 species they're bringing back the
dinosaurs Chris Pratt and Bryce Dallas
Howard caught it cuz apparently
underneath this home they have like a
giant prison and lab massive something
for some reason James Cromwell totally
surprised to find out about how do you
think you could get away with this
because in your home you have a prison
and you've got you don't even know how
many rooms are yeah that's why he
thought he didn't get away with this
like everything's happening like he just
bought the estate then maybe but even
then that's pushing it there's a lot in
this movie that gets explained away with
one line of dialogue well they try to do
this whole human drama element James
Cromwell the granddaughter this guy I
don't remember the character's name of
the actor's name the bad dude so
irrelevant I'm like I just don't care
about this drama I'd rather just stick
to you being mustache Hurley kind of
villain who wants to here's where the
movie's wildly baffled because they had
two motivations with the dinosaurs
that's when I thought this script
especially sucked why do they have two
distinct motivations with the dinosaurs
to militarize them
and to sell them to like rich evil guys
or something why do you have both
motivations in this movie how do they
coexist these two motivations when you
never get to walk around inside of them
so we're never any of the wiser really
we just know that rich people want
dinosaurs when they're actually
auctioning off these dinosaurs that's an
audience member I was sitting there
going this is the definition of a stupid
horror movie now
what's the worst kind of horror movie
where you feel like you are a million
times smarter than the characters in the
movie because the entire time they're
auctioning off you're like the people
buying them are idiots and the people
selling them are idiots how is this in
any way a good idea for anyone as an
audience or watch it going this is just
stupid this isn't scary
this is stupid and then I'm like wait
why do they have this whole militarizing
the dinosaur story when did they bring
it back that was the one thing that I
couldn't stand in the last movie why
they bring it back and it doesn't even
really serve a purpose here when they're
saying they want to do it here's where I
got especially annoyed Henry Wu shows up
the evil doctor who was a good guy in
the first Jurassic Park and now they
made him the big saw villain no visitor
eyes yeah always shown him at the end to
collect his samples and run off to the
next Island or when he showed up this
movie suddenly felt like the most
expensive b-movie I've ever seen yeah
especially in his portrayal yeah when
they're auctioning off the dinosaurs 20
million 30 million 50 million this is so
stupid this is so dumb what are they
gonna do with these dinosaurs good keep
them in a cage you can have them run
around again at these guys you gotta use
an Allosaurus to play cricket yeah oh
yeah we can control them to be like
attack enemies something you don't see
people like [ __ ] higher lions and
[ __ ] you know let me see dee dee this
was a dinosaur then I thought the
characters are especially dumb when the
Indo raptor comes out my first question
is if they're not planning on Sunday
Indo Raptor why show why are you
displaying the Indo Raptor to everyone
then it made me question the entire
point of Henry's character he's okay
with them selling the dinosaurs and I'm
like why why is he okay with them son I
could kind of get on board with him
wanting to militarize them but why is he
okay with just like yeah rich
shouldn't bad guy he's sure you get out
of [ __ ] dinosaur and it had to be
Russian oh there are subtle nods to the
political landscape in here Paul's the
one veterinarian girl a nasty woman oh
yeah
yeah I didn't pick that up again till I
saw it for the second time when they
interrupted people start bidding for it
and Henry's like what are you doing it's
just a prototype immediately I'm
thinking who gives a [ __ ] if it's just a
prototype what do you think they're
gonna do with the other dinosaurs these
other dinosaurs that are not prototype
so you're just gonna have under control
no prototype or not none of these three
being sold right now as the creator of
these dinosaurs how do you possibly
think this is a good idea
and then would especially hit the nail
for me was the fact of how this all goes
to [ __ ] is because I'm sitting there as
an audience ever going manage guys are
dumb what [ __ ] up everything for these
humans a little dinosaur who likes to
headbutt people not even the scary like
[ __ ] terrifying dice like head but
people and stab them who cute
head-butting dinosaurs and that one
little thing got loose and [ __ ]
everything up for everyone listen Lana
Soares all it takes is one of any of
them that's why I was like why would you
possibly sell any of these no motivation
in this movie made sense to me that's
the only thing I could figure for that
part is like these are probably a bunch
of people who've never seen them before
and don't know what they're dealing with
and that little headbutt dinosaur jaws
gave them a taste yeah and we talked
about the the elephant in the room with
the little clone girlfriend yeah reason
yes thank you let's get into that the
little girl in the movies not James
criminals
granddaughter it's apparently the clone
of his daughter who was killed in a car
wreck watching the movie for the first
time when they revealed that like that
was the point where I just really like
visibly next to a bunch of my friends
slash co-workers and showed my
frustration watching it a second time
you see all of these clues that lead up
to the big reveal
oh did I look like my mother oh yes you
were mirror image of her and you're just
like screw all of you well that's the
thing here you're watching this movie
about genetically altered dinosaurs and
stuff like that and then when they bring
up like oh she might be a clone it's
almost doesn't have an impact because
there's just crazier science and things
that are extinct engineers like a
hodgepodge dinosaur to kill stuff I'm a
little more concerned unless you're
gonna tell me she's got Raptor blood or
something no way the way they reveal it
is specially like the way they
expositionally reveal and the guys do
you even know she is they have the wide
eyes like what the [ __ ] is this thing
I'm like what I do care they're saying
this is rare Hammond and James Cromwell
had a falling-out
remember that line in the movie like I
don't care about this it really feels
like a non-sequitur ooh twist like let's
just put something else here okay this
is a whole other movie that I do not
care just watch right now who gives a
[ __ ] about this plotline and anything I
hate about this movie too is how non
subtle it is it's just yeah so beyond
the point of subtle to you from
beginning and even little things out
when I rewatched Jurassic Park there was
something about dr. ham that I'm not
sure was intentional but that's maybe
I'm not sure it's intentionally because
maybe it was subtle when I look at dr.
Hammon and he kind of has his god
complex about him I love that he is all
in white the whole movie and he's got
the white be like he looks like a
traditional portrait of God and he he
views himself as a god-like person for
this journey and he has that warmth and
that father leave yeah yeah but not one
point does he go I'm [ __ ] God yeah
there's one point in this movie where
bad guy practically looks at Chris Pratt
a Bryce Dallas Howard and goes you're at
him in your Yves he's your
responsibility right yeah like like John
McClane in this movie you know when he
has that thing with Hans Gruber was like
really it's just about money at the end
of the day like that's exactly how I
started about the villain it was like
yeah like can we get for one of these
Jurassic park's a philosophy for a
villain to have beyond just like I'm
gonna make a fortune everybody gets
something better than that
Indo Raptor breaks loose in the dumbest
way oh yeah what
okay so military guy shows up what the
hell are you and then try starting it
yeah I think you said right a lot go in
the cage so good as stupid as his
decision was to go in the cage I like
the way the Indo Raptor moment in that
scene was actually handled when he opens
his eyes and closes it yeah it kind of
has a sail yeah and it kind of has a
smile on his face like I'm at the
[ __ ] eat your ass yes I actually like
that moment and then when he eats him
that was cool it was kind of distracting
however zero blood
it was cool-looking the arcane omni
falls off like that was a neat moment he
dies a horrible death mana guy was the
guy who set up out of the horrible a -
that was like with like a plier endo
Raptor breaks loose trailer reveals most
of what happens from here on earlier
right when that happened
a tiger from like Oh have you seen the
treasures like what happens well little
girl's gonna eventually go to her room
and the wrappers gonna go in there Chris
Pratt's gonna print all of this Chris
Pratt's gonna break in he's gonna fail
to take it down the blues go to show
beginning in the ng you just don't care
about in the Raptor stuff is so like
mixed in with what is cool like there's
some cool ass shots with the endo Raptor
for sure there was logical things about
the interrupter that just didn't quite
bode well for me you could already
Jurassic Park has already done this
before these dinosaurs are [ __ ]
amazing and hunting down bad people like
the characters that deserve to die yeah
the amazing but when it comes to heroes
they just such intelligent and dangerous
animal in the world it is [ __ ] stupid
the only part I liked with it what it is
going after than our good guys was oh
good landed its claw Bryce Dallas Howard
for a second yeah at least that happened
it was more like a poke but yeah yeah
but even when they're going up the
stairs no no I don't buy the inner
rapper would have at least slashed one
of them easily easily would have just
got one claw across them yeah but Chris
Pratt the whole movie my reason in
contact with any dinosaur it's just a
little one oh my god t-rex oh my god
this thing's looking me oh my god in the
grass
not the money maker when the interrupter
finally makes it outside what happens to
all these dinosaurs get outside they
[ __ ] leave right screw this I'm outta
here whole world out here some reason
the endo Raptor turns this movie it's a
full-blown Universal horror movie it
literally reminded me of Benicio del
Toro's / Wolfman at one point when he
goes up to the roof and it's rainy and
there's the moon yeah he practically
howls like why is the Wolfman that's the
twist I wish it was more like the moon
goes down in his revealed that it is the
little girl yeah this is like she turns
into the Indo Raptor don't give Colin
Trevorrow any ideas and it was kind of
an underwhelming moment too when they
have the showdown at the roof like I
thought it was kind of clever when Bryce
Dallas Howard miraculously shows up I
know where they are the roof even though
I'm like in a completely opposite side
of this Johnny TAS mansion right now
mechanics off-camera
and it only doesn't work because of its
tone that's the main thing I got to keep
coming back to is his tone is not
treated as a cheesy entertainment fest
like Jurassic world this is treated in a
way where it wants to be taken seriously
so she shows up and I like how okay
that's smart they're gonna make me late
it'll fall through the glass clever and
I thought it was cool that endo Raptor
like doesn't fall through actually yeah
I'm like oh that is pretty scary then no
Raptors actually just know this might
not work and then the obvious part blue
shows up and the only surprise of this
movie to me was blue did it die I
thought blue was gonna get hit with the
spikes so it's cool when she doesn't get
killed if I've called blue he at any
point during this review I'm sorry so
sorry I forget that it doesn't have a
penis and a vagina because they do a
bunch of close-ups on it yeah I love
when blue kills that in director things
like a two second look yeah
let's just talk about the ending of this
movie now hoo-boy
the one truly intriguing thing about it
the ending of this movie if it had
occurred earlier playing I'm talking
like act 2 and you get the movie in this
plot the movie has a surprisingly good
hook for the next Jurassic world movie
yeah it does because I'm like that seems
like an interesting sci-fi film right
there us living amongst dinosaurs that
sounds [ __ ] crazy that's like a war
with Dinosaurs you might even get that
like crazy another day you might even
get that crazy plot movie where there
were like little strapped guns to the
Raptors welcome to Jurassic I can do it
no Gary the day before I watch this
movie I flat out called that ending
because the trailers show you most of
the movie and then the trailers have the
one shot with that they show at the end
which pretty much tells you how this
movie's gonna end with them the
Mosasaurus area getting some surfers
that trailer moment goes oh the
dinosaurs have all like I've broken out
they're here on our lands now yeah well
the fact that Ian Malcolm also says
welcome to Jurassic yeah and I think
that's a cool intriguing ending cuz
they're all going their separate ways
and you know like they might reproduce
they might there might be more than they
might just kill a bunch of people cuz
Rand it's only a few dinosaurs but we
know what one dinosaur can do this could
be a mass murder situation it's not a
property damage it's very loose weight
with Jurassic Park one sets up is that
life finds a way for these creatures to
reproduce even if they don't intend on
that science the science changed their
gender freaking Henry who's probably
gonna like I'm gonna make more of these
you know I think that's a really cool
setup for the movie I still feel like
the movie doesn't come to a clear
understanding of what its message is it
sets up a debate but the movie doesn't
settle on which side it's on it sets up
should these dinosaurs live amongst us
should they not live amongst us the
whole finale of the movie is [ __ ]
dinosaurs terrifying a [ __ ] yeah and
then they live amongst us they really
bungled the ethics debate in this movie
because they do just make them all to a
degree look pretty monstrous this even
right before that finale Bryce Dallas
Howard the clone
girl goes just like me you know beep
beep yeah this is that part of the movie
right before scary finale
it's scary finale heartfelt moment for
dinosaurs the back to scary ending when
it really was at the core of that moment
is a fascinating debate because that's
the conundrum Jurassic Park raises in
and of itself is like we created these
things they are alive there are concerns
for this but we can't just let them out
to destroy everything on stem yeah what
do we do easy you put them on another
island that already has dinosaurs on
board that apparently everyone else
forgot exist there's a whole like lost
world I believe yes can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
Bell check us out patreon full-length TV
show reactions weekly Q&A is music video
covered the real mr. Dobson over here go
check out his channel yeah that's
fantastic stuffs real mr. Robinson
checking me out on YouTube Instagram
Stardust any other form of social media
you can find me on yes Alex Johnson
thanks for being here buddy glad to be
back after three years reviewing another
5th minute